[whoosh]
- Elvin is part of a series of
events puzzling investigators--
nine shark attacks
along the Southeast
Florida coast in 2017, more
than double the average.
And with leads coming up
short, some local authorities
come up with their own
theories for the spike.
Vero Beach Ocean Rescue's
Eric Toomsoo explains.
- In my experience, it's based
on a few different issues--
people in the water, number one.
Number two, how
clear the water is.
Usually there's--
it's murky water
when we've had an incident.
[splashing through water]
- Murky water-- it seems
like an innocuous detail.
But witness Jessica Veach echoes
the idea that it's important.
- There's a lot of
sand being churned,
which makes it hard
for the shark to see
what it's actually fighting.
- Could the shark's ability
to see in murky water
be the one thing that ties
all the attacks together?
According to Dr. Huber,
sharks are adept at navigating
murky water--
relying on other senses.
- In murky water sharks,
can lean more heavily
upon the lateral line and
the electrosensory systems
in order to locate their prey.
- But he does think there is
a unique limit to a shark's
vision that could have played
a role in some of the attacks.
And it has to do
with available light.
- We're bringing
out a spiny dogfish.
- To investigate, Doctor
Huber performs an eye
dissection using this
common shark found
in waters all over the world.
- I'm getting towards
the back of the eyeball.
We'll be able to free it up
and remove it from the skull.
This is the back
half of the eyeball.
One of the really interesting
things about sharks' eyes
is that they have a layer
of reflective crystals
that coat the back of
the eye with a thing
called a tapetum lucidum.
And what this does is it
actually causes night shine.
You may have seen night
shine on your cat or your dog
or on a variety of
different animals.
- In humans, light passes
through the eye once.
But for sharks in dark
waters, the tapetum lucidum
bounces the light back--
letting the eye process
images a second time.
- In layman's terms,
this basically means
that sharks have night vision.
- But as the sun begins to
rise, a shark's eye must
react to the increasing light.
- You can think
of when you first
open your eyes in the
morning and things
seem a little bit too bright.
After a few seconds, your
eyes accommodate to the amount
of light in the room
and then you can see
things as you normally would.
And in sharks, this process
can take anywhere from a half
an hour to potentially
a couple of hours.
- It's a process called
visual accommodation.
During these periods of changing
light, like dusk or dawn,
a shark's vision
may be compromised--
potentially leaving
swimmers vulnerable.
During these times, sharks
are very, very active
looking for their prey, which
would increase the probability
of a shark attack if
people were in the water
at those same times.
[music playing]